I of course like everyone grew up
watching your films loving your movies
but something very special to me is I'm
grew up a huge Johnny Carson fan and
watching him was watching him made me
realize that's what I want to do when I
grow up I think you may have been the
best guest of all time on The Tonight
Show with Johnny Carson he loved you
what do you think made your chemistry
special I was in love with him and I
felt that we had a connection somehow I
don't know why we just did it didn't
make it happy that was jealous
it was Jo the sidekick always gets do
whatever you want I don't care but there
was a there was he was I think almost
more relaxed I think around you than
just about anybody and that was from the
get-go from the first time first time
out of the box I'd I couldn't believe it
and I'd heard all these stories you know
don't touch the pencil be careful when
he reaches over yes don't drink out of
the cup buddy you know right right all
his room don't look directly into his
eyes don't look good
[Applause]
I just I just didn't give a damn about
all that yeah and and we had a good time
we always had fun I've heard I've heard
a story I don't know if it's true that
Johnny Carson had you on the firt on
your first appearance on The Tonight
Show and he had such a good time he said
that night come back tomorrow
is that right that's true yes that's
unbelievable
and I think you did maybe the rest of
the week I slept there that night hoping
you to sleep with him yeah look we got a
cot out back you're just letting yeah
yeah I'll let you know here clearly not
interested
[Applause]
you